So earlier this week, Republicans dragged
Sally Yates into a Senate hearing to investigate
their continued conspiracy theories about
the Michael Flynn investigation.
And it went so poorly for them.
Remember that Sally Yates is the former deputy
attorney general.
She's criticized the Justice Department's
decision to drop the prosecution against Michael
Flynn, who is, as a reminder, the former Trump
national security adviser who had been indicted.
So Republicans have cooked up all sorts of
different conspiracy theories, many of which
go through Sally Yates.
And Republicans control the Senate at least
until January.
They brought Sally Yates in to testify via
video conference and it just went so poorly
for Republicans.
I want to show you a few clips now.
She testified about how the Obama White House
first became alarmed about Michael Flynn's
behavior, that Flynn was having secret discussions
with the Russian ambassador before being sworn
in.
He was talking to Mike Pence about things
that really stunk to high heaven.
So Yates explains that it was investigated.
Plain and simple.
There was really no scandal there.
But, of course, Republicans have been desperate
and continue to be desperate to claim that
there was an Obama administration conspiracy
to take down Trump.
That includes the Obama administration illegally
spying on the Trump campaign.
All of this different stuff.
They want to claim that it was investigative
of abuse and much more.
But take a look at how badly this imploded
in their faces.
Sally Yates facing a very hostile panel of
questioning from Republicans.
Here's Lindsey Graham.
May maybe one of the most unhinged brownnosing
Trump sycophants trying to play prosecutor.
And he doesn't like Sally Yates's answers,
so he keeps interrupting.
And Senator Patrick Leahy tells him, hey,
Senator Graham, just because Sally Yates is
a woman doesn't mean you have to keep interrupting
her, which is hilarious.
And it kind of threw Lindsey Graham off for
a moment.
Take a look.
Now, let's talk about January 5th meeting.
Was the vice president there?
Yes, he was.
OK.
Did he mentioned the Logan Act?
You know, I remember the vice president saying
much of anything this week.
So you don't remember him mentioning the Logan
Act?
No, I doubt that anybody mentioned the Logan
Act.
I have a vague memory.
Director Comey mentioning the Logan Act.
Was he mentioned Logan?
In what context?
Well, I'm not sure he mentioned that in the
Oval Office meeting or in the meeting.
What do you think about that German?
Let her answer that question, because a woman
testified as much as we can.
Thanks a lot, Senator Lee.
I really appreciate that.
You were very constructive.
So here's my question.
Lindsey Graham is so horrible and he does
have a challenger in a Senate race.
I want to remind you that Jamie Harrison is
running against Lindsey Graham.
We could remove by we I mean, the voters of
South Carolina could remove Lindsey Graham.
That's an interesting race to follow and maybe
get involved in continuing.
Here's a video of Ted Cruz saying, when did
you first learn that the Obama administration
was spying on the Trump campaign?
Gates says that never happened.
And Ted Cruz visibly flummoxed.
Miss Yates, when did you first become aware
that the Obama administration was surveilling
the Donald Trump campaign?
The Obama administration was not surveilling
the town to keep.
Just a bizarre moment, I mean, this is desperation
from these Republicans and of course, all
of this is meant to distract from the disaster
after disaster after disaster.
That is the current Trump administration.
And Ted Cruz actually continued to propose
things that never happened during his questioning
of Sally Yates and Sally Yates continually
had to continue putting him in his place.
Take a look at another example.
So a FISA application is not surveillance.
The FISA application was for Carter Page,
who was a former member of the Trump campaign
at that point.
So your testimony is that that the investigation,
Carter Page, had nothing to do with the Donald
Trump campaign.
Now, I'm suggesting you ask me if we were
surveilling the campaign.
You don't get it both ways.
Is it the campaign or not?
Senator, I'm trying to give you what is the
accurate information.
Carter Page was a former member of the Trump
campaign at the time that the Fizer was initiated.
And what was the reason for the files on Carter
Page?
There were a number of reasons, first, we
had gotten the information that I was trying
to point out here that the Russians had made
the overture that they wanted to be able to
assist the trunking, said it had nothing to
do with the Trump campaign.
I said that he was not a member of the Trump
campaign at the time.
We appreciate it.
Now, the really sad thing is that in Republican
circles, they see these same videos and they
see this as really brutal questioning from
Ted Cruz.
The salivates fell apart.
It's semantic games.
It's it's really a lesson, actually, in how
the right makes their arguments.
And it's a lot of semantic games and optics.
And I wish it didn't work, but it works.
If you look at how Republicans respond to
McCain, McKinnon, his press briefings, you
know, Caylee comes out and she scolds the
media.
And then she always has some scripted walk
out.
That is it.
Like it makes me cringe when I see it.
But there are people who love it, the vapid,
scripted walk offs and the attacks on media.
Many of us accurately see them for what they
are, which are just completely empty, vapid,
meaningless optics.
But there are Republicans who love it.
And Donald Trump junior will retweeted as
Caylee owns the media.
And that's exactly the same thing that happens
with briefings are with testimony like this
where the questions Lindsey Graham is asking,
the questions Ted Cruz is asking.
They are dumb leading questions.
And Sally Yates has no choice but to say that's
not true.
That's not true.
But there is a contingent that says, wow,
she really fell apart.
Let's look at just a tiny bit more.
Cruz just keeps going here.
So when they came to you asking to surveil
members of the Trump campaign because of conduct,
they allegedly did while members of the Trump
campaign.
What due diligence did you do?
Did did did you press back at all?
You already told Senator Kennedy you just
trusted the FBI.
You didn't ask about their sources.
You did.
I mean, what due diligence did you do before
signing off on?
What we now have significant reason to believe
was a profound politicization of law enforcement
and intelligence.
Senator, that puts a tremendous amount of
process back and forth between the lawyers
and the national security litigation at the
ICC.
I asked what you did not not other lawyers.
What due diligence did you do?
You were the one signing off on it.
And we respect whether the facts were accurate
in this instance.
Did you inquire whether it was opposition
research funded by the DNC or Hillary Clinton?
Yes, I did have a discussion about that.
So it was hours of this stuff.
Hours and hours.
And it's like trying to squeeze water from
a rock.
It's like there's a lake where all the water
is.
And that's the disaster after scandal after
embarrassment of the Trump Trump administration.
They ignore the lake where you could just
go and drink the water.
And instead they focus on picking up, picking
up rocks and trying to squeeze water out of
them and pretending that the lake doesn't
exist.
Then we'd better thank them for trying to
squeeze water out of Iraq.
It's it's pathetic.
It's going absolutely nowhere.
But if Trump wins in November, you can expect
a lot more of this.